قلما تجد شيئا انجزه الذكر لم تستطع
الانثى انجازه اصبح الطبيبه ورائده فضاء
وقاضيه ومقاتله وثائقه شاحنه وقطار وعداء
ورباعه وبطلت جودو اكبر حدث رياضيا نسائيا
في اوروبا نظمته جمعيه كاريرا ديلامخير
الاسبانيه شارك في الحدث الرياضي 32 الف
سيده لانه سباق طول السباق سبعه كيلو
مترات الكل كنا يرتدينا اللون الوردي
النساء المشاركات كنا من مختلف الاعمار
وايضا من مختلف الجنسيات ارتدينا قمصانا
عليها رقم 016 هو رقم الطوارئ المخصص
لضحايا العنف من النساء المنظمون يقولون
ان السباق يسعى لمحاربه العنف ضد المراه
وتوعيه بمرض السرطان وادماج النساء من
مختلف الاعمار بالرياضه وتعزيز نمط الحياه
الصحيه
اما عن الفائز
السيده الفائزه في المرتبه الاولى بهذا
السباق هي هذه السيده
الصربيه هما اختاني توام اسمها ايفانا
زاغوراتش اذانا زغورات حققت المركز الاول
تجاوزت اثنين
الف سيده شاركت في السباق اما الهديه
اللافته التي حصلت عليها فهي هذه سيدتي يا
سيده المطبخ جهاز الطبخ متعدد الاستعمالات
لراحتك وراحه زوجك واطفالك خلاط طنجره ضغط
طحانه بن وقدامه بقيمه الف واربعمائه يورو
وزيره الدوله لشؤون المساواه ومناهضه
العنف ضد المراه في اسبانيا انتقدت هذا
التكريم واسمها انجيلا رودريغيز تقول اذا
فزتي فانت ربه منزل وعلى عكس ذلك ستخسرين
على الاقل بعض الوزن لا تكمن المشكله في
اللون الوردي ولكن في ده مش شركات له
لتستر على ما هو مهم مثل محاربه الذكوريه
ما زلنا بحاجه لمزيد من السباقات كيف علق
الناس على اهداء الفائزه جهاز طبخ في
المسابقه الداعمه للمراه
يقول من المؤسف ان تشارك
32 الف امراه في سباق مدريد وتكون الجائزه
جهاز مطبخ ايا الحسين قالت خلاط في رساله
من الجائزه لانهاء لانها غير مناسبه للحدث
سباق والجائزه خلاط ما بتركب ماذا لو كان
الفائز رجل عبد الفتاح الموسى قال لك ولم
لا هي جائزه بكل الاحوال يعني لو تلقيت
مثل هذه الجائزه ساكون سعيدا جدا بكل
تاكيد ساهديها لزوجه مباشره
سعيد يهديها لزوجته لورا تقول لك مو على
اساس الغرب تطور المراه تساوي الرجل خير
شو رجعهم للمطبخ
ابو ذر يقول لك ما في تمييز اذا فاز الرجل
يهديه لي زوجته واذا فازت المراه اخذته هي
على كل حال الجهه المنظمه ومن شده
الانتقادات طبعا للسباق وللهديه اعتذرت
واضطرت لتوضيح الهدايا تقدمها الجهه
الداعمه المحتضنه للسباق وفي حالتنا هذه
جهاز روبوت المطبخ لم يكن جائزه للسباق بل
هديه الجائزه الوحيده التي يمنحها
المنظمون هي الكؤوس اما بالنسبه للفائزه
في السباق اذانا زاكوراتش تعلقت على
التكريم بالقول شكرا للمنظمين والمحتضنين
ولكل السيدات المشاركات شاركنا جميعا من
اجل محاربه العنف القائم على النوع
الاجتماعي
والترموميكس الذي حصلت عليه سيسهل حياتي